we're going austin yay
we're meeting up the big mood girl we're
gonna do a panel out there and meet some
of you guys and then we're gonna go to
dallas and then go to orlando yeah it's
a three-part trip we're going to disney
world and universal like oh my god this
next two weeks is going to be a
whirlwind
[Music]
actually
[Music]
like that what was that i didn't expect
this to squeak
welcome to our room we're standing at
universal's cabana bay
it's like the 1960's yes it's so cute
it's still 1960's
we're actually here for six whole days
we said goodbye to my cousin jenny and
her family it's funny because she's
actually flying to california tomorrow
but
kind of like switched
it'd be funny if she was going to
disneyland
because then she flies to your home area
to go to disney and rehearsal and then
we fly to their home area for for disney
for a while
yeah such a cool voice you know we
actually visited every place that casey
has lived in yes
la dallas orlando oh my god
i never lived in hong kong
we are from there
no parents are from i'm from texas it's
like saying you're from peru from mexico
yeah i'm really tired man we've been
traveling for ten straight days up until
this point are we ready for the next
couple of days non-stop theme parks with
this guy
all right this is isaac's room um like
the living room area yeah so while tiff
is breastfeeding we're gonna set up
isaac's room okay
what's next
some sheets yeah
don't look too closely but no what is
this
i'm the type of person that sleeps uh
like goes in the bed with the shoes
weird i'm pretty uh like whatever about
stuff but even i don't do that everyone
used to make fun of me for sleeping in
my jeans really because i used to sleep
in my jeans all the time everyone's like
how is that comfortable
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
much better much much better
[Music]
okay baby
yeah someone's excited to go to the
theme park today i don't forgot which
theme
to animal park
look at he's like he's like come on you
guys all right come on we gotta go we
gotta go
you're the only sane person here i know
we're it's 9 00 am we slept in because
we were
exhausted yeah we're going to animal
kick them that's why we're wearing our
animal-ish shirts yep and i i tried
because this is safari-colored looky
bear
luckster
oh i forgot we can't leave i gotta feed
this kid oh okay well
sorry
[Music]
my inner child is like screaming right
now i finally get to come to animal
kingdom
look at this guy
all right we are in animal kingdom now
we're gonna have isaac lead because well
he's the most excited out of all of us
and uh he's been wanting to come here
the most prepping the modes he's done
his research his take talk research
on what the best rides should be and we
should be going on and he's gonna lead
the way which is great because look at
that i want to come here and not have to
think cool look at that person
oh there's also animal viewing i forgot
it's a zoo yeah it's animal kingdom oh
this is the standard for zoos all zoos
should be like this zoo should have
animals and roller coasters see worlds
like that it's like a aquarium ah
sea world's the standard for aquariums
baby luca
he's awake
wild boy in his natural habitat
[Music]
all right so isaac and i just finished
riding whatever this ride is yeah
dinosaur land dino
planet and i feel like i missed you for
sure now baby
i missed yourself
hi cutie i haven't seen you in there for
like an hour
yeah so the line was like an hour long
all right let me tell you something
that's nice
and isaac is carrying battery packs for
us to recharge things and forgot the
cables
oh sorry we're gonna say i interrupted
you oh yeah
i was just saying like waiting in line
away from baby is painful yeah
i'm gonna have to do that right now no
you don't you you got the swap rules
right so i'm gonna have to go wait in
line right now what i thought it was the
lightning lane oh yeah
he was sleeping for a little bit take a
little five minute nap yeah
oh we're back yeah look at it he likes
dinosaurs
oh cute
hi baby you're playing with the dinosaur
down here
how cute i love that he's reaching for
things now
look at him exploring i'm being
stimulated
he's already playing with his with toys
like this is the first time i've seen
him reaching for stuff
literally he hasn't reached for anything
he just like walked up to one cause i
was getting bored too let's look at some
dinosaurs and then he started touching
them away
that's so cute
[Music]
we fell asleep right before we got on
and now that we're off he woke up
all right luca and i came to the baby
center baby care center and have
a private
nursing room huh luka
you happy we get some privacy because up
until now i've been feeding him in the
restroom because this entire part every
disney park here only has one baby care
center i'm like this is for kids you
should at least have them on opposite
ends of the park but anyway we made it
here to this one oh luka
yes
cutie you hungry yeah i like how there's
a rocking chair changing table luckily
this little boy doesn't need a diaper
change but
if he did we can do it here with ease
and the boys are waiting for us at
starbucks
you ready to eat
[Music]
hey hi
okay are you more comfortable now
he gets to see the world yeah
you get to see what we're looking at i
hadn't put them around earlier in this
trip yet because he seemed kind of small
for it
but
he seems fine now he grew within this
yes he did grow on this trip because
right before coming on the trip i tried
putting him uh-huh forward-facing and
like his
his like mouth was like on this thing oh
[Music]
that's sick i've never seen this before
baby's first ride i don't think you can
see anything huh
he's looking though he's looking
everywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so heartwarming to see luca
experience his first ride i know it
means the world to tiff she absolutely
loves disney and theme parks and
obviously isaac loves disney and theme
parks and to see luca join in on the fun
helps me join in on the fun as well
because i've never been a theme park guy
myself but seems to enjoy himself and
smile and as a parent it's a feeling
that is irreplaceable it's it's better
than anything in the world and yes you
probably won't remember any of the trip
but i like to think that that memory
still serves some sort of emotional
anchor so if we can give him a little
bit of joy and happiness that makes me
happy all right so we're going to take a
brief pause on the video and talk about
our sponsor today and let's talk about
privacy as content creators we are
constantly putting all sorts of
different informations about ourselves
out there on the internet it's great
that you and i can go on this journey
together but it also means we have to be
extra extra careful in 2020 49 million
americans were victims to identity theft
and it ended up costing them a combined
56 billion dollars now this isn't just
happening to people who are making
youtube videos or people who have bad
passwords over 37 billion records were
hacked in the year 2020 alone off of
social media sites crypto exchanges
phone and internet providers and that's
why i'm excited to partner up with aura
who is sponsoring today's video aura
uses ai and machine learning to protect
your identity online you tell aura what
email addresses account numbers and
phone numbers you want monitored and
their algorithms scour the dark web data
brokers and public records and will
alert you to any criminal activity fast
their vpn allows you to stay anonymous
online and keep your browsing history
and personal information safe and
encrypted they have antivirus softwares
that will block any malware and viruses
before they infect your devices now
check this aura has actually found my
personal information on the dark web 12
different times that's crazy if you sign
up for a free trial because of this
video leave in the comment section down
below how many times your personal
information was found on a dark web
see if you beat my number so don't put
your family at risk love them cherish
them protect them try aura free for two
weeks and see if your personal
identifiable information has leaked to
the dark web dun dun dun start your free
trial at aura.com tiffcase or click my
link in the description down below
alright make sure to protect your
families and enjoy quality family
bonding time back to orlando
[Music]
all right day two and we are at where we
at hollywood studios hollywood studios
yeah we just want to find the sign of
course we're at hollywood studios i'm
really bad with this stuff and obviously
we're in hollywood because look you've
got the chinese theater raw men's
theater is that what it's called now or
they change the name yeah they changed
the name they changed the name it's a
chinese theater to me i don't know but
yeah it looks like la we're back home
got the fan going and day two is
treating the baby pretty good so far
nice and cool in there
i just realized i forgot two very
important things in the hotel room oh no
i forgot the the cable again to charge
the fans so we made the same mistake as
we made a mistake and i pumped milk last
night and i forgot to bring the bottle
ah so you're on your own with feeding
him again again yeah yesterday we
actually um made a very
good mistake which was uh we got in line
for the pandora
avatar
path of flight
flight of pass something
avatar right between me and tip one of
us is going to sacrifice the time to be
in the home with isaac
and two hours
yeah and we did and we decided that i
was going to be the one and it would
stay we didn't know it was going to be a
three hour wait and yeah yeah it ended
up being a three-hour wait and had i
stayed back i'd have been so
royally
fudged you don't have breast milk
because i don't have breast milk
[Music]
all right i don't know how much i've
vlogged since we got actually we didn't
vlog that much but we did one ride it
was the
rock and roll looking one um that one
was sick yeah what's it called uh rock
and roll rock and roll roller coaster i
was actually close yeah
but yeah now we're eating at the world
famous uh
what is this place called
[Music]
luca baby you're missing all the rides
you're so fun
[Music]
yeah
this is like a renaissance affair look
at this this is
this is really cool
look at these guys
yeah
this is still part of the line
oh it's not the right yet that's right
this is cool
oh you're scaring me it's an
interrogation
what's up youtube we just got saved by
the resistance i've never been a part of
a renaissance bear this is really cool
it's like very immersive all right we
should have more like uh
[Music]
he looks so happy
[Music]
we're gonna go on another ride baby your
second ride of your life because the
safari doesn't really count because you
were sleeping
[Music]
[Music]
this is kind of intense
[Music]
all right we got day three
we're going to epcot and i finally
remembered to bring the milk that i
pumped two days ago nice and i have that
cable to recharge our fans in one of the
backpacks
he's been dying to leave yeah i feel so
bad it's already 11 today because
like the later like the more days we're
doing it the later we're waking up
because the more tired we are true all
right walking up to the big golf ball
look at the size of that golf ball
[Music]
all right we're headed to mexico
my people and half of him and half of
him yep
luka rick's torino do the sound of the
garbage
[Music]
we got to see my peoples now it's your
people yes
this is your culture too baby
[Music]
we're about to get on guardians
i'm going the second time you're going
for the first time yeah so chess said a
lot of good things best ride ever
honestly probably dang
yesterday we did rise of the guy
rising resistance
and that was pretty good all right we
are inside
[Music]
[Music]
all right so hands down i'd say gardens
of the galaxy is the best ride ever that
was my most no favorite right worth
every single ounce of hype that there is
for this ride oh my god this ride was
amazing i've never had
as much fun i've never danced on a
roller coaster like that was so freaking
cool like i in the middle of it i'm like
oh my god this ride is amazing it's so
fun i can't believe i'm on here this is
so cool and then when i think it's over
i'm like and then it keeps going i'm
like oh my god this rollercoaster is so
cool oh my god i'm having so much fun i
don't know if we mentioned it in the
vlog yet but isaac has been able to get
on
all the cool rides twice because
we have the rider switch
so thanks to his brother his little
brother isaac gets to ride all the rides
twice
that's been really cool but me and casey
haven't been able to ride anything
together unless it's like a family thing
that's true all the kitty rides
oh it's about to rain oh we're running
we're running all right so isaac and
tiff are about this life they're like
rain
who cares
we're continuing you're about this
lifetime super bowl
you're so troubling
i think the baby's protected baby's
protected
you got this life
yep
[Music]
all right so we finished the night with
uh ratatouille but we had we gotta get
out of here now go go
you look so cute kind of protected from
the ring thank you
[Music]
having fun yeah
i'm actually really enjoying myself it's
weird too i'm like really happy it's
refreshing
it is not a fan of wet socks wet clothes
are not fun
aside from that not too bad
my shoes are troopers
my socks still aren't wet and they're
like
[Music]
all right day four let's go
are you
this little guy
this morning actually the last two
mornings or three
mornings
anyway what i was gonna get at is the
fact that luca every morning has had a
wild adventure with his diapers
especially him he changes the morning
diapers and i change the rest of the
diapers throughout the day and he's the
one he's a morning pooparoo skis
for sure he likes getting most of his
business done at night i mean in the
morning
and it is crazy yeah see that crazy we
need to wash his whole pjs and all that
anyway i think he's just more
comfortable with me you know i think he
prefers me
[Music]
all right let's go
universal studios florida
all right today we are at hollywood
studios number two
aka
universal studios because they created
hollywood again
here at universal studios it's been a
whole lot of time complaining about it
being like hollywood but this is new
york oh what really you walked from l.a
to new york already at that
oh we're in san time now
king's cross we're in london so you can
complain that this is another epcot
okay fine
thank you
yeah you gave me a win yeah
[Music]
all right we walked into the cut oh snap
this is cool
you guys know that i love complaining
about how stupid theme parks are but
deep down i really do like theme parks
[Music]
what are they doing what are they doing
they're doing something
[Music]
what's it do
[Music]
oh it's raining over there
they pointed the magic the wrong way i
guess
oh my god they activated something
they made it earthquake yeah
[Music]
i got towed in the hole
i use a mash for isaac
and you got what i got mini pies
shepherd pie and a mini something else
pies
fisherman's pie yeah
british food okay let's try some pudding
they're putting it different for an
american pudding it's like a
like bread oh that's why they call it
bread pudding
all right
just another day in florida florida
rains too much yeah baby's okay he's
just sleeping oh look you can see a
little like feather light amount of
water on his hair i don't think the
camera's gonna pick it up luckily we
decided to leave because we were
literally contemplating whether or not
to do homework another ride yeah we're
like uh those clouds look crazy let's
just leave we don't want to go through
the same thing we went we got our buses
here oh oh well we're getting hit
hello good morning or good afternoon
really because uh
it is 1 33 today
and we
have finished all our amusement park
days and yesterday we went to
uh
adventure island or island of adventures
didn't vlog yesterday because
i wanted to take a break from the vlog
and uh
try to have a chill day i guess today's
the day we'd fly back to
california and we're going to use the
final day to look at some houses
found a few um open houses so we want to
check out what the homes are like and
the neighborhoods are like see if it's
something that we like because we do
like the fact that there's disney here
which is always fun especially with
family and all and the humidity here
most people would say it's not so great
because people generally don't like
humidity but for me who has eczema and
dry skin problems the humidity has been
great and that's something i
am
definitely enjoying and that's one of
the top reasons why i would consider
moving out to orlando so yeah so we're
heading out to the first house we
actually have not eaten because trying
to figure out how to rent this car by
the way yes tiff is driving
hi and um decided to rent the car
because
we didn't want an uber everywhere we
were going today and we figured that
it's going to rack up quite a bit of
money um having the convenience of
having our own car we can breastfeed we
can change diapers we can do all that
stuff too with luca so that's easy look
at sleeping
but yeah we're going to the first house
and uh excited to see what it has to
offer
[Music]
you